fallout from the Muller report continues
Michael avenatti faces down handcuffs
but not the kind that he likes and
vice-president pence heads to AIPAC I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so there's a lot of news to get to today
there's some breaking news about jussie
Smollett that we will try to get to if
time permits a lots and lots of stuff
happening right this very instant but
before we get to any of that let's talk
about the fact that our federal
government is out of control it's been
out of control for a very long time and
it's been out of control because the
federal government has essentially been
restructured to run roughshod over the
checks and balances that were inherent
in the Constitution of the United States
and this is why I am a big believer in
calling a convention of states where we
the people can propose amendments to the
Constitution to protect the Constitution
itself from the predations of the
federal government that means overreach
by the executive branch means overreach
by the legislative branch it means the
legislative branch kicking too much
power to the executive and the executive
kicking too much power to the judiciary
it means Congress threatening to undo
the power of the judiciary it's time to
protect the Constitution that's why I'm
a fan of the convention of states can
you imagine the look on the faces of
members of the federal government when
they realize their power has been
limited and that suddenly they have to
go back to the original founding bargain
of a limited government well this is
what a convention of states can help
make happen in fact a convention of
states may be the only way to get the
job done there are already 3.8 million
people with us on this more every day so
join me and my friend mark McClure go to
convention of states calm slash bend to
sign the petition today that is
convention of states calm slash Benton
let's reinsuring the Constitution at the
center of American life convention of
states calm slash men go sign the
petition today and join mark McClure and
me to help restore constitutional checks
and balances convention of states calm
slash bad all righty so yesterday I was
not here for our afternoon show for the
additional two hours of the show we
kicked it over to the execrable michael
moles who had himself a field day I am
told I'll tell you how my day went so I
had an endoscopy scheduled for a while
and it just turned out that it fell
yesterday and so they gave me some
propofol and they put me under to do
this endoscopy and when I woke up I saw
that Michael avenatti was being
prosecuted and the icebergs in Greenland
were growing and I thought to myself am
I still under sedation and did I somehow
end up in president Trump's fever dream
what exactly happened here because Wow
like every 20 minutes there was a piece
of news that was breaking for president
Trump in favor of President Trump most
of yesterday of course was consumed with
the reaction to the William Bar Attorney
General report on the Mullen report it
was a four-page summation that we read
on the podcast yesterday all about what
exactly Muller had found and it is
necessary at this point to point out
that the reactions of the people who had
over zealously suggested what was in the
report are astonishing to watch it is
astonishing to watch as people double
down on the confirmation bias that got
them here in the first place and this is
unfortunately a typical human tendency
you are called out on something that
debunked your original position and
instead of you starting to reconsider
based on the evidence or take the
evidence into account instead what you
do is you simply double down on your
original perception of the issue and you
look for excuses as to why this is all
somebody else's fault now this does not
mean that it is not hilarious because it
is indeed hilarious the most hilarious
story of the day comes courtesy of the
New York Times here's the headline quote
disappointed fans of Muller rethink the
pedestal they built for him it would
take a heart of stone not to laugh at
this quote is by Astia Herndon and
Richard Fawcett the sense of mourning
started to take hold over the weekend
after Attorney General William P Barr
said that Robert S Miller the third the
special counsel had not found
coordination between President Trump's
campaign and the Russian government's
election interference in 2016 over the
nearly two years of the Muller
investigation a segment of liberals and
activists built up fervent hopes that it
would bring mr. Trump down they elevated
mr. Muller a former FBI director into an
anti-trump cultural icon complete with
t-shirts scented candles and holiday
theme songs like we wish you a Muller
Christmas for some of them the report
felt like a betrayal to many others it
was a disappointment that's a hell of a
range of emotional responses there I
mean from betrayal all the way to
disappointment my goodness I was hoping
the truth would come out said Sean
foster a 45 year old music video and
television producer in Nashville mr.
Foster had taken to wearing a yellow pin
showing the top of the special
prosecutors head rising like a shark
from the sea mr. Foster said he was
wearing the pin on Sunday when mr. Barr
summary of the report came out its
definitely embarrassing he said it's a
drag knowing there are people out there
who are gloating well yeah
also we've all been laughing you the
whole time dude like it's not just now
like the whole time we've been laughing
at you now there's some of us who daily
wear funny hats on top of our head
because we want to it reminds it of the
Providence of God in the universe there
are some of us who wear shirts that
proclaim political messages you know
general political messages and then
there are some of us who elevated a
person that we did not know anything
about and who is just a prosecutor into
a national icon in the fervent hope that
he would be the deus ex machina who
ended the trump presidency it's just
wonderful
Jennifer Tabb a Vermont Law School
professor who'd become known for punchy
anti Trump columns with titles like yes
collusion now what said there are
definitely people who thought that
Muller would save us and Miller looks
back at them and he said no just pretty
amazing the media malfeasance here of
course has been absolutely egregious now
are the media admitting to their
malfeasance of course they're not how
many articles since May 2017 have been
published about Russia and Trump slash
mower since May 2017 is according to
Axios five hundred thirty three thousand
web articles have been published about
Trump and Russia generating 245 million
interactions so the media did all of the
election interference that the Russians
didn't do in 2016
apparently this is all according to news
web and on the networks alone the
network's alone gave two thousand two
hundred eighty four minutes to the
Russia probe according to News Buster's
and that's just the network's right
those are the people who have like an
hour a night to give you the network
news if you go to cable then you are
talking presumably in the tens of
thousands to hundreds of thousands of
minutes because that's been basically
CNN's main programming for the last
couple of years and it's not just that
they have been programming this stuff up
the wazoo it's also that they've been
breaking false bombshells
four legitimately years on end The Daily
Caller has a really good piece about
this by Amber athle the White House
correspondent pointing out all of the
ways in which the media botched this
story you'll recall that CNN accused Don
junior of WikiLeaks collusion she writes
last December CNN's Manu Raju reported
that WikiLeaks emailed Donald Trump jr.
to give him access to stolen documents a
full ten days before they were released
to the public
and then it turns out their sources gave
them the wrong date Don jr. received an
email with access to the stolen
documents after they've been released
publicly
remember that ABC tanked the stock
market with fake Mike Flynn news ABC was
forced to suspend Brian Ross after he
falsely reported that former national
security adviser Michael Flynn was
prepared to testify that then candidate
Donald Trump ordered him to make contact
with the Russians the stock market
dropped a few hundred points at the news
but the news turned out to be fake now
here's the thing he could say this is
all just the media getting it wrong
listen over at Daily wire we've had four
attract headlines before we've gotten
stories when we published legitimately
50 to 70 stories a day and you do that
over the course of several years and
you're talking about thousands and
thousands of stories the question is in
what direction do all the mistakes get
made so at our site we're a conservative
site we openly acknowledge we're a
conservative site CNN ABC these are
outlets that pretend to be objective and
yet oddly every error they ever make
cuts in one direction in one direction
only how strange
you remember that CNN reported that the
mooch was under investigation and the
mooched got an apology from CNN because
the mooch was not under investigation
first of all the mooch was in the
administration for a grand total of 32
seconds I'm not sure what he would have
done in those 32 seconds to earn an
investigation other than being the
greatest guest star in the history of
Trump the television show Bloomberg
suggested that which bank was being
zeroed in on by robert muller jeff
Sessions and Jeff Sessions who was
reported had botched protocol CNN said
that that he had botched protocol and he
didn't list meetings he had with the
Russian ambassador on security clearance
forms but sessions met with them when he
was in the Senate needs story after
story after story and yet do the media
feel really contrite today of course
they don't I mean people wouldn't
Pulitzer Prizes for this stuff guys
people in the media won Pulitzer Prizes
The Washington Post and The New York
Times won the 2018 Pulitzer Prize for
their national reporting of president
Trump's alleged collusion with Russia
they received the award this is Town
Hall reporting for quote deeply sourced
relentlessly reported coverage in the
public interest that dramatically
furthered the nation's understanding of
Russian interference in the 2016
presidential election and its
connections to the Trump campaign
the president elects transition team and
his adventure administration deeply
sourced well not so much not so much
because it turns out that half their
stories were sourced incorrectly
there was an article for example they
published on Jared Kushner the report
talked about Donald Trump jr. Jared
Kushner and mana fort Paul Manafort
meeting with a lawyer connected to the
Kremlin in reality they met with Natalia
vessel Mnet's kaya who was with fusion
GPS the group behind the fake dossier
the Washington Post did the same thing
you'll remember it was the Washington
Post reporting that jeff sessions had
met with Russian ambassador Sergei his
lyac proving proving that collusion was
on the menu it turns out that sessions
met with his lyac because he sat on the
Senate Armed Services Committee and the
media's malfeasance can be summed up in
this one clip from Chris Matthews never
hire Bob as they say remember Chris
Matthews coming into the show rolling in
here in the middle of the mother
investigation could Mathias it comes out
there comes out of a show Rose on in
there he says you know what I think I'm
an aquatic metaphor is it at the
aquarium the other day my wife Kathleen
or at the matter we were at we're at the
aquarium and I died too much a drink as
per my usual arrangement I started
thinking that is starfish there's a clam
it's a mallard Trump go watching mower
and Trump collided I'm reminded of
biology lab back in my sophomore year at
LaSalle Kies High School remember the
starfish in the clam I know we decided
one or the other definitely the starfish
MOA reminds me of the starfish which
gets itself tight on the clam and uses
all its stuff that we can and pry open
the clam now this is a battle to the
death as far as the clam is concerned if
the starfish is able to open him even a
little bit he can get open him open all
the way and that's it of course for the
clam
he's the starfish his lunch the starfish
in the climb this is how the media
relentlessly reported with deeply
sourced reporting on Trump and Russia
and mother starfish to the clam guys
she's like high school biology class
I failed by the way inside but it's okay
now I'm here running and here my funny
chair my weird hair yeah well done
mediate so in a second we will show you
how the media are so apologetic about
their mistakes you know they
really bad that's the nice thing is that
they have they have really learned their
lesson yet not so much we'll get to that
in just one second first let us talk
about life insurance so you may be
thinking right now that your laughs fit
to die but you shouldn't do it until
you've got life insurance getting life
insurance can feel like assembling the
world's worst jigsaw puzzle it's
confusing it takes forever and when
you're finally done it doesn't even look
cool but if you've got a mortgage kids
or anyone who depends on your income it
is a puzzle you need to solve and policy
genius can help you do it policy genius
is the easy way to get life insurance in
just two minutes you can compare quotes
from top insurers and find the best
policy for you when you apply online the
advisors of policy genius will handle
all the red tape they will even
negotiate your rate with the insurance
company no Commission sales agents no
hidden fees just helpful advice and
personalized service and policy genius
doesn't just make life insurance easy
they also make it easy to find the right
home insurance auto insurance or
disability insurance they are your
one-stop-shop for financial protection
so if you find life insurance puzzling
head on over to policy genius.com this
is the responsible adult in two minutes
you can compare quotes find the right
policy and save up to 40% doing it
policy genius it's the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance go check
them out right now policies units the
easy way to compare and buy life
insurance now as I say one of the
beautiful things about the media is that
when they make a mistake they are happy
to acknowledge it they're really good
about acknowledging the mistakes that
they've made so for example people live
like Jeff Zucker right the head of CNN
who came out and said no actually we did
great
CNN president Jeff Zucker quote we are
not investigators we are journalists and
our role is to report the facts as we
know them which is exactly what we did
oh is that what you did that was now I
get it that's all you were doing you
were just reporting the facts as you
knew them never mind there's an entire
section of the CNN website called CNN
investigates no they don't do any
investigations they're just there to
report the facts as they know them like
the fact that Trump was Russian catspaw
and it's not just Jeff Zucker who is
defending the media's behavior in all of
this it's so funny you remember after
2016 the New York Times ran an editorial
in which they said yeah we sort of got
this whole thing wrong our coverage we
sort of missed a few things
well now self-reflection has become
taboo in the media and so it's no we
didn't guys we did great we did great
you know it's not that we got a 9
her SATs is that the test is biased
that's what happened here so the New
York Times writes today after Muller
report news media leaders defend their
work by amie chazak there have been
tipping points and bombshells walls
closing in and turning points and there
have been so so many declarations at the
beginning of the end
the comedian John Oliver had a recurring
satirical we got him segment on his late
night HBO show complete with jubilant
marching band and sequined majorettes
celebrating president Trump's downfall
but in the swirl of reporting and
speculation about the 45th president
nothing has held viewers on the edge of
their seats quite like the Special
Counsel Robert Muller the third and his
investigation into possible ties between
mr. Trump's 2016 campaign and Russian
agents the storyline had it all cold
war-era intrigue allegations of shadowy
meetings in Moscow and all of the rest
the news media got it wrong obviously
but are they feeling bad about any of
this
no no that's silly sucker said in an
email a sitting president's own Justice
Department investigated his campaign for
collusion with a hostile nation that's
not enormous because the media says so
that's enormous because it's
unprecedented
well except if the media coverage helped
drive the investigation in the first
place bill grew skin' a professor at the
Columbia School of Journalism we're all
good journalists go said Muller and bar
need to prove beyond a reasonable doubt
do we file charges or don't we
journalists don't have that standard in
other words Pulitzer prize-winning
reports of alleged wrongdoing do not
need to provide evidence of criminality
in order to be factual newsworthy and
relevant to readers that's not really
the question the question is whether you
blew all of this out of proportion and
suggested that around every corner lay
the end of the trump presidency Martin
Baran executive editor of The Washington
Post said quote the Special Counsel
investigation documented as we reported
extensive Russian interference in the
2016 election and widespread deceit on
the part of certain advisors to the
president about Russian contacts and
other matters our job is to bring facts
to light others make determinations
about prosecutable criminal offenses
Dean Baquet executive editor of The
Times said we wrote a lot about Russia
and I have no regrets it is not our job
to determine whether or not there was
illegality that's right it isn't and yet
strangely it seems as though your entire
narrative is that the president was
about to be impeached how strange see
there are two types of bias there's bias
in how you cover a story and then there
is selection bias in what you choose to
cover and the media demonstrated
both here I'm gonna show you case in
point Chris Cuomo over at CNN so case in
point Chris Cuomo over at CNN
here's a flashback this is a month ago
he said the president Trump would
certainly be under pressure after the
Mullen report this was not
editorializing this was objective news
off' occation journalism in at the
highest level chris cuomo journalism
journalism in all over everyone this
block of wood the less smart of the
Cuomo brothers which the hell of a
statement here he was a month ago saying
that President Trump would be done done
done done done under pressure this is
gonna be an especially chaotic time his
president will be under pressure and all
likelihood like he's never been before
not because he's gonna be removed in
cuffs but because almost certainly he's
not gonna like things in the report but
get ready a storm is coming expect the
president and his allies to throw
everything they have at you to make as
much noise as possible to distract and
obfuscate and expect those who seek
advantage in any negative information to
spin it fast and hard as well
okay well spinning fast and hard is
actually Chris Cuomo's main job at CNN
yesterday Rudy Giuliani called him out
on this he said maybe you should
apologize for your coverage and Chris
Cuomo is like me know me I'm great I'm
the best journalist you've ever seen
I've journalism all over everyone
everywhere here's Chris Cuomo defending
his dumb eNOS you guys yes network what
have I done have tortured this man for
two years with collusion and nobody's
apologize for their before we talked
about if throw there was apologized for
the overreaction it's illusion not a
chance of course you're not not a chance
fair no please you know better than that
you know I don't know better I am
outraged by the behavior of these
networks okay collusion collusion
collusion collusion pollution assorted
leno calor okay here's my here's nope
here's my case apologize never here's my
que never never I didn't do anything
wrong these questions are real I I need
to be regarded as such reason they
needed to be investigated oh well oh
well so as Chris Cuomo has got nothing
to apologize for guys nothing they're
their total coverage over at CNN has if
you watch CNN you could have come down
on either side of the issue either Trump
was a traitor or or he was also a
traitor
those were the two sides of the issue
that you could have come down on if you
regularly watch CNN I know because it
was on at the gym all the time while I
was working out so it's not like I've
never watched CNN okay
watch CNN for two years do this routine
and yet the media are they going to take
an introspective look and maybe maybe
whether they ought to provided a couple
of different perspectives maybe whether
they ought to taken a breath before they
reported that the president was probably
in league with Vladimir Putin maybe they
should have stopped acting so
overwhelmingly excited every time they
appeared on TV with a new piece of
bombshell breaking news maybe not enough
they're not gonna do any of those things
the best example of confirmation bias at
work was on the view yesterday because
the members of you like Joy Behar are
the bumper sticker version of CNN
they're the sort of people who do where
Muller pins around the office here was
Joy Behar beside herself yesterday she
couldn't deal with the fact that the
Muller report had not been everything
that she had hoped that it would be I
have questions about obstruction why did
he why did he keep his conversations
when put with Putin's secret those are
like little questions that sound like
obstruction to me so I don't buy that
he's completely exonerated the way he
just said well he says he's completely
bashing him up on that I'm reluctant to
talk about it at all because you know we
don't know anything and we have not seen
this report so I think everybody needs
to pump the brakes when we talk about
this being a huge victory for this
administration guys we don't know
anything like two days ago we knew
everything we knew that Trump was a
traitor now we don't know anything we
got to hold up guys we got a hold up
there you remember they did the exact
same thing with trustee Smollett as soon
as Jessie smell that came out with his
story it was you know this is evidence
of American racism deep-seated brutal
American racism same thing with
Covington high school this is evidence
of deep-seated brutal American racism
and then the facts started to leak out
it was you know we got a hope you know
let's let's wait a minute let's wait
let's hold up let's make up our minds
after we see all the evidence it's
always interesting to see when people
say let's wait for the evidence and when
people are willing to jump beyond the
evidence at hand always very interesting
because it is a good way of revealing
bias every human being has a tendency
toward this stuff but the media are
overwhelmingly biased in one direction
now I will say that the media's bias is
not any shock to me I think that the the
greatest shock to me is the continuing
malfeasance
I mean true malfeasance of high-ranking
members of the intelligence community it
is severely disquieting to me that so
many high-ranking members of the Obama
intelligence community these are people
who are supposed to be tasked with
protecting us from terrorism protecting
us from threats foreign and domestic
that these folks are so politically
biased that they went on television
night after night proclaiming that the
elected president of the United States
is a traitor and that he would be proved
to be a traitor
with no evidence none I mean John
Brennan the former head of the CIA under
Barack Obama he was head of the CIA when
the Trump Russia investigation was
initiated he was on MSNBC last night
after spending legitimately two years
proclaiming that he had secret knowledge
that President Trump had committed some
nefarious act of treason he was on MSNBC
last night he said oh well you know my
mistake I guess I mean like I just you
know I guess I thought that there was
more than there actually was oh well I
don't know if I received been efficient
but I think I suspected that there was
more than there actually was and I am
relieved that there has been determined
that there was not a criminal conspiracy
with the Russian government over our
election I think that is good news for
the country I still point to things that
we're done publicly or efforts to try to
have conversations with the Russians
that were inappropriate but I'm not all
that surprised that the high bar of
criminal conspiracy was not met a
whoopsie doodle you know you know just
spent the last couple of years
suggesting from my perch at the top of
one of America's foremost intelligence
agencies using the expertise that comes
along with that position proclaiming
that the president is a traitor to the
United States I guess I just got a
little loud ahead of myself you know
it's understandable really to call the
president of the elected president a
traitor you know we were investigating
during the campaign on the basis of
scanty to no evidence but sure you know
everybody makes mistakes guys it's not
just John Brennan a former FBI official
named Chuck Rosenberg was on Meet the
Press and he said that Mulder's decision
not to come to a conclusion on
obstruction quote strikes me as a little
bit curious because what prosecutors get
paid to make determinations and
recommendations or perhaps he didn't
have the evidence to determine whether
or not obstruction took place but now
we've got a former FBI official using
the expertise of his position to
proclaim that maybe
something nefarious is going on there
and it doesn't stop there I I don't know
how we are supposed to trust our
intelligence community when they are so
obviously and thoroughly politicized and
talking the top-level people it's funny
at every major American institution
they're the low level people who
actually do a lot of the day-to-day work
those are the ones who are trying to
track down crime stop terrorism and then
there are the political officials who
are appointed and they are supposed to
be granted this patina of expertise and
legitimacy well they have blown it I
mean absolutely blown it I will show you
more evidence of that momentarily first
let's talk about how you can hire better
you shouldn't hire somebody like John
Brennan or James clapper you should hire
somebody competent and that's why you
ought to have zip recruiter hiring is
challenging there's one place you can go
where hiring is simple fast and smart
it's a place where growing businesses
connect to qualified candidates that
place
zip recruiters calm slash daily wire zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and then invites
them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruiter to
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you're never gonna miss a
great match zipper career is so
effective that 80% of employers who post
on zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the very first
day and right now my listeners can try
zip recruiter for free at this exclusive
web address zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire that is zip recruiter com
slash Dai ly wir zip recruiter com
slash daily wire zip recruiter is indeed
the smartest way to hire don't hire duds
like apparently our intelligence
community heads were instead go hire
somebody competent go to zip recruiter
comm slash daily wire and try it out for
free zip recruiter comm slash daily wire
ok so it is not just John Brennan of
course it is also James clapper the
former head the former Director of
National Intelligence under Barack Obama
who has spent two years proclaiming
loudly and proudly that doom was
impending for president Trump that we
were moments away from the end of the
Trump administration well here he was
yesterday saying no regrets no regrets
guys here he was do you regret anything
you have said in terms of raising
questions about the president's behavior
or some of the things the president has
done or said
no I don't and I have put that in
writing in my book as well I have I have
concerns and as do others and I have
tried to be factual and temperate not
about it but but I do have concerns and
no I don't have any regrets he husband's
no regards he's getting a tattoo right
across his neck that says no regrets
good stuff there from from James clapper
people who use that legitimacy as former
heads of our intelligence agencies to
proclaim nonsense for two years it
should make us ask questions about
whether the heads of our intelligence
agencies ought to be trusted I'm a fan
of a lot of folks at the FBI I have
friends who are in the FBI
I'm fan of a lot of folks at the CIA I
think they're doing really important and
good work but it makes me question the
competence of the heads of these
intelligence agencies when they spend
two years being openly political and we
were supposed to pretend that they were
not political when they were Obama
administration appointees and when they
were working for Obama they were
absolutely apolitical they were not
politicizing the intelligence agencies
they headed and then they spend the next
two years just spouting absolute bull
crap on national TV and then they don't
apologize for it no you know we were
just misinformed
we were just misinformed if the
Democrats have been doing the same
routine now many of the Democrats are
trying to kind of quietly brush past us
you're saying Nancy Pelosi you say
listen I think that we're done here
right there's no there's no more to see
here many of the Democratic twenty to
twenty twenty candidates are just
remaining silent on this entire issue
meanwhile their backup plan is to
proclaim that they don't have the full
mullah report so they can't make a
judgement on any of this stuff six
democratic committee chairs in the house
according to NBC News sent a letter to
attorney General William bar on Monday
requesting that he submit the full
report from the special counsel Robert
Muller's Russia investigation to
Congress by April 2nd which would be the
beginning of next week
they say his summary is not sufficient
for Congress that's true but he's going
to have to redact presumably some
material from thousands of pages under
federal criminal regulations if there's
Criminal Procedure Federal Civil
Procedure rules and under Criminal
Procedure federal procedure rules 6 e is
the one that was cited by by Jay by
William Barr in his letter he has to
redact information because otherwise
it's you legal otherwise he
could be committing a criminal violation
and so the Republicans voted down a
proposal to force him to release the
entire report forthwith he's gonna
release this stuff it's gonna confirm
all the stuff that we already know it'll
talk about the Trump Tower meeting it'll
talk about connections between Mike
Flynn and members of the Russian
government when he was the incoming NSA
it'll be all the stuff that we already
know and then it will be the conclusions
that Barr has laid forth this thing is
over okay it is unless there is some
berry bombshell that I think Muller
probably would've leaked by now
considering how much play this has
gotten that this thing is over and
Democrats can't accept it the dumbest
senator in the Democratic caucus is
mazie Hirono from Hawaii who's proved
herself to be absolutely feckless and
terrible over the past few years she
says you know who's happy today Vladimir
Putin is happy today because booty Putin
he's got his man in the White House and
Moe I missed it how does she know that
she's mazie Hirono gumshoe sleuth she's
encyclopedia brown of the Senate just
because there was not enough evidence
for a criminal charge of conspiracy does
not mean that there's a very cozy
relationship that Donald Trump has with
Putin who by the way must be really
happy that this came about that this
kind of cozy relationship that is not
good for our country in that it's not
transparent will continue okay yeah I'm
sure that's it I'm sure that that
Vladimir Putin is is secretly now
working with Trump that's what it is the
doubling down is really astonishing
sheldon whitehouse the senator from
Delaware he said the same thing he says
you know muddler just didn't have enough
power that's the real problem here as
miller didn't have enough power do you
think it makes sense for Bob Barr who
spends two years trying to discern the
truth and the justice here to turn it
over to a guy who just got appointed
Attorney General to make a ruling on the
final ruling on the issue of obstruction
of justice no because the whole purpose
of Special Counsel is to have somebody
make prosecuted decisions outside of
politics so to take the prosecutor
decision and hand it back to the top
political appointee in the office
defeats the whole purpose of being
Special Counsel oh that is that what it
is sheldon whitehouse by the way from
Rhode Island not Delaware there he is on
on Chris Matthews making that idiotic
point and no the DOJ is charged with
prosecution Muller gets to decide
whether he feels that there is enough
evidence to warrant a prosecution or not
he said he didn't really have a judgment
when it came to obstruction of justice
because Trump had said a lot of things
and then the AG has to decide whether to
prosecute or not that's normally the way
that this works the illegal the legal
imbecility of sheldon whitehouse his
comments they're pretty obvious
Elizabeth Warren who has just become
like again
I knew senator Warren when she was a
professor at Harvard Law School not well
but we'd had a couple of interactions
everybody at the at the law school knew
about her she was actually an
interesting person back then now she has
basically just become Bernie Sanders
with Native American background so here
she was explaining that the real problem
here is attorney general bar on Stephen
Colbert who hopefully hopefully
hopefully I mean he's just looking
hopefully into Elizabeth Warren's eyes
as they as they lock eyes and dream of
the day that Robert Muller comes back
come and they're like the kid at the end
of Shane crying plaintively out to the
plains Shane come back Robert come back
here is Colbert and Warren's doing that
routine
do you trust bars judgment on
obstruction here no you shouldn't have
to ask me if I trust it we should see
the whole report when we see the whole
report we'll know what the basis is yeah
there's still hope guys we're going to
impeach him based on obstruction but the
entire Democratic leadership Pelosi
Schumer like yeah we're probably not
gonna do any of that stuff now are any
of the Democrats backing down from their
overwrought points no Cory Mac Book er
Spartacus Nick face over here he was
asked whether he would correct his
claims that there was Trump Russia
collusion he says me correct claims no
no real collusion going on you said do
you now have to revise that to say not
chargeable collusion again would I have
a Attorney General who in my opinion is
suspect filtering a report that I have
not seen I'm not willing to conclude
anything yet
based upon a letter that he wrote okay
so then that's you know he's not gonna
retract anything not at all not at all
now teams from has reacted to all of us
and they've reacted with the proper
outrage and Kellyanne Conway called on
Adam Schiff who has set up an actual pup
tent inside the CNN headquarters
been forced to evict like a homeless
person under Rudy Giuliani in Times
Square Adam Schiff is now living on the
streets once more walking around with a
sign that says the end is near
collusion collusion so Kellyanne Conway
says about Adam Schiff yeah that guy
should resign from the Intelligence
Committee he's a joke this is correct
Adam Schiff talk about an oxymoron this
man had the Intelligence Committee in
the House he said quote he believes that
the scandal is of a size and a scope
probably bigger than Watergate and that
there's plenty of evidence of collusion
here honor resign today you're saying
that we did not win fairly and squarely
you in fact running around shutting your
jaw out and saying I'm worried about the
effect on the institutions you were
disparaging the institutions you were
demeaning and dividing our great
democracy the presidency of the United
States Adam Schiff should resign she is
correct about this and as you know I've
been very critical of Kellyanne Conway
for being an over-the-top Lackey for the
Trump administration well she is not
wrong on this one in a second we're
gonna talk about how Trump stay got even
better there was a cherry on top of the
ice cream that that was provided by a
man named Michael avenatti who's turned
out to be just the best thing that ever
happened to Donald Trump we'll talk
about it in just one second first you're
gonna have to go over to Daley wire calm
and subscribe for $9.99 a month you can
get a subscription to daily wire you
know what you get with that first of all
if you get the $99 a year the yearly
annual subscription you get this the
very greatest and beverage vessels he
left this year's hot or cold tumbler it
was overflowing continuously yesterday
flooding houses around the nation you
can have one of these for $99 a year and
that comes with all sorts of goodies it
means that you get access to two
additional hours of happiness and joy
every afternoon because we are here
every afternoon with you for two hours
it means I'll answer your questions in
the mailbag and also during the breaks
on my show it means that our Sunday
special becomes not only the Saturday
special for you but you can get it on
demand at commercial free in you get
extra questions with the guests
afterward I mean all sorts of amazing
goodies and wonderful stuff happening
for you when you become a member over at
Daley wire.com also I would remind you
that my book is still number one in
nonfiction at Amazon it is still number
one in nonfiction over at over at Barnes
and Noble as well so go get a copy of my
new book the right side of history which
continues to sell like hotcakes because
it is delicious and filling just like
hot
go check it out don't eat the book go
check it out the right side of history
it is it is I think an important and
important work so you can check all that
stuff out get a subscription go check is
how YouTube iTunes leave us a review we
always appreciate helps us with our
rankings over on iTunes particularly
where the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so president Trump's winning was not
done yesterday you know President Trump
promised winning winning until it hurt
winning so much winning that we would
beg him to stop the winning well
yesterday was his winning estate now I
do have to note that when we say it was
his winning de-stank not politically
right not in terms of conservative
priorities but in terms of the showed
and Freud of watching the entire left
collapse in on itself like a dying star
yesterday was pretty spectacular so the
truth is Trump was elected to spit in
the eye of the radical left and he has
done that repeatedly and that's been
very satisfying for a lot of members of
his base if you're a member of Trump
space yesterday was pretty much the best
day you've had since your first child
was born it was pretty spectacular
because not only was Trump cleared on
the collusion stuff not only did the
media have to look themselves in the
mirror and then ignore what they saw but
also Michael avenatti a man champion is
a possible 2020 candidate you know the
lawyer the lawyer for stormy Daniels he
was a fighter
hashtag Busta Michael avenatti a man who
appeared on the view and said that he
wanted to see president from marched out
in handcuffs not only that he said his
sexual fantasies included handcuffs
always here's what he had to say on the
view all of my sexual fantasies involve
handcuffs and who looks like she's just
gonna vomit all over him the proper
response there from Meghan McCain it
turns out that he's going to enjoy his
sexual fantasies for a while here
because they have frog marching somebody
out in ain't Trump it's Michael avenatti
best story of the day so good so he was
arrested he was arrested because he
tried to extort Nike stand for something
even if it means going to jail for
extortion solid stuff there a federal
magistrate judge in New York ordered
avenatti released on three hundred
thousand dollars bond in cases alleging
that he embezzled money from a client
and tried to extort millions of dollars
from Nike and then he claims no no no he
was just standing up with the people
also implicated just to make this even
better was Mark Geragos Mark Geragos the
celebrity attorney for justice Millette
was named as a co-conspirator in a case
accusing lawyer Michael avenatti of
trying to extort Nike both of these guys
were CNN contributors remember when the
media didn't have anything to apologize
for
avenatti of
59 times in one month during one period
a couple of like a year ago there was a
picture of him with Don Lemon celebrate
yucking it up and Chris Cuomo and the
whole gang over at CNN Michel Avignon he
was the guy he was he was he was gonna
fight president from to the end and now
Michael avenatti is probably going to
jail he is probably going to jail
because he's an idiot it turns out
honestly I didn't come up with this but
it is the best description
Michael avenatti is the Jacob wool of
Michael Cohen's it's just spectacular
Michael avenatti turns out to be the
most incompetent doofus maybe in legal
history so here's what he tried to do he
tried to go to Nike and then blackmail
them with information about how a
representative of Nike had been paying
off recruits to use their shoes or
something but he was not quite that
discreet about it at first he went to
them
he went to Nike and he said that he
represented an AAU coach who seemed had
previously had a contractual
relationship with Nike but whose
contract Nike had recently decided not
to renew according to avenatti his
client had evidence that one or more
Nike employees had authorized and funded
payments to the families of top high
school basketball players and their
families and attempted to conceal those
payments similar to conduct involving a
rival company that had recently been the
subject of a criminal prosecution
avenatti said he plans to hold the press
conference the following day to
publicize the asserted misconduct at
Nike he said he had approached Nike now
because he knew that the n-c-double-a
tournament was about to begin and he
knew that their quarterly earnings call
was scheduled for March 21st thus
maximizing the potential financial and
reputational damage his press conference
could cause to Nike he said that he
would let it go if Nike paid to his
client 1.5 million dollars and then hire
avenatti to conduct an internal
investigation of Nike with the provision
that if Nike hired another firm to
conduct such an internal investigation
Nike would still be required to pay
avenatti at least twice the fees of any
other firm hired so then the attorney
for Nike called up the cops and they
said okay let's have a meeting let's had
a meeting so avenatti showed up to the
meeting and then repeated all of this in
front of law enforcement apparently this
is the allegation and this is what he
said he's such a he's such an idiot thug
avenatti reiterated threats made during
the previous in-person meeting I guess
he did this over the phone along with
his demand for a multi-million dollar
retainer and he said he wanted to be
paid at least ten million dollars and
leave the bag of money in the parking
lot in particular a vanadis stated quote
I'm not effing around with this and I'm
not continuing to play games
you guys know enough now to know you got
a serious problem and it's worth more
and exposure to me to just blow the lid
on this thing a few million dollars
doesn't move the needle for me I'm just
being really frank with you so if you if
that's what if that's what is being
contemplated then let's just say it was
good to meet you and we're done and I'll
proceed with my press conference
tomorrow
I'm not effing around with this thing
anymore so if you guys think you know
you're gonna negotiate a million five
and you're gonna hire us to do an
internal investigation but it's gonna be
capped at three or five or seven million
dollars let's just be done I'll go and
I'll take ten billion dollars off your
clients market cap I'm not f fing around
and then he said that he had the abandon
other-- meeting where apparently he said
the exact same thing and at one point he
suggested that he would quote unquote
cut cut off their their balls this was a
quote from Michael avenatti he's he's so
wonderful Michael avenatti they said all
of this in front of while he's being
recorded apparently by law enforcement
so it's all going great for Michael
avenatti
it was so bad that stormy Daniels dumped
on him I mean not like that guy saw me
Daniel's put out a statement quote
knowing what I know about Michael
avenatti I'm saddened but not shocked by
news reports he's made that he has been
criminally charged today well when
stormy Daniels is now dumping on her own
lawyer a person she called Michael
Angelo of the legal Michael Angelo of
the legal profession you know things
have gone bad so great day for president
Trump and Michael avenatti remains a
he's got a problem
he's got problem he's gonna get to
fulfill all his sexual fetishes soon
enough in prison the the reality show we
didn't know we needed is Michael
avenatti taking Jacob world Wasco in
prison
okay meanwhile breaking news prosecutors
have dropped charges against Jesse
Smollett the Empire actor is supposed to
forfeit ten thousand dollars bond
payment and have the records in the case
sealed sealed just over a month after he
was charged
does that sound like privilege to you
that sounds like privilege to me now
I've been told that the only privilege
that matters in America is white
privilege but it turns out that if you
fake a
crime you'll remember the justice
Millette faked a hate crime he pretended
that he was garroted by a couple of
Trump supporting Magda had at idiots in
the middle of Chicago at 3:00 a.m. who
were shouting this is mega country in
the middle of a polar vortex the good
news was just he never lost his Subway
sandwich who's holding on to that Subway
sandwich forever it turns out the entire
thing was a hoax it cost probably
hundreds of thousands of dollars to
Chicago PD to investigate this stuff
hundreds of man-hours that could have
been spent on y'know actual crimes is he
gonna be charged with anything nope
they've dropped all the charges they say
he already did community service
according to the smollett defense team
the community service was done prior for
something not related to this case just
stupid garbage stupid garbage from the
prosecutors I mean honestly the the the
federal the federal prosecutors ought to
go after him and nail him to the wall
this is insane
according to the Cook County
Prosecutor's Office who apparently there
were reports that they were interfering
even in the cpg investigation and the
Cook County prosecutors were deeply
afraid this was going to go how it
eventually went they said they put out a
statement quote after reviewing all of
the facts and circumstances of the case
including mr. Smollett volunteer service
in the community an agreement to forfeit
his bond to the city of Chicago we
believe this outcome is a just a
disposition an appropriate resolution
absolute crap absolute nonsense his
record has been wiped clean wiped clean
they're not even going to have a record
of him pleading guilty to something like
this their statement today all criminal
charges against Jesse Smollett were
dropped his record has been wiped clean
of the filing of this tragic complaint
against them this is the statement of
his defense attorneys jesse was attacked
by two people he was unable to identify
On January 29th he was a victim who was
vilified and made to appear as a
perpetrator as a result of false and
inappropriate remarks made to the public
causing an inappropriate rush to
judgment Jesse and many others were hurt
by these unfair and unwarranted actions
this entire situation is a reminder
there should never be an attempt to
prove a case in the court of public
opinion that is wrong
Jesse SMO it was not a victim he faked
by every piece of evidence a hate crime
this is absurdity at the highest highest
level just amazing and just growth don't
worry guys the Justice Department in
Chicago
is is doing its best the
criminal-justice - I mean if you are the
CPD head you have just got to be enraged
right if you are a if you are the head
of the Chicago Police - the
superintendent of the Chicago Police
Department who came out with all the
evidence you have got to be fighting mad
today smollett continues to insist that
he was innocent that statement from his
attorneys is of course a lie
Smollett was originally indicted on 16
felony counts for falsely reporting a
hate crime by a grand jury and the
charges were summarily dropped because
the guy is a celebrity and because he
has connections inside the prosecutor's
office is the best possible guess here
federal prosecutors should now move
forward full-scale with prosecuting him
that should be the next move we will
bring you more information as it breaks
meanwhile over at AIPAC it's really
interesting a gap is breaking out in the
Democratic Party so Mike Pence the vice
president of the United States spoke at
the American Israel Public Affairs
conference this happens every year it's
a huge event tens of thousands people
show up and people from synagogues all
around the country because AIPAC is the
pro is a pro-israel lobbying
organization they don't spend they don't
give money to candidates or anything but
they do spend an awful lot of time
talking to various members of Congress
and Mike Pence went directly after
representative Ilhan Omar and the
burgeoning anti-semitism inside the
Democratic Party anti-semitism has no
place in the Congress of the United
States of America and at a minimum
anyone who slanders those who support
this historic alliance between the
United States and Israel should never
have a seat on the Foreign Affairs
Committee
and of course all of that is true when
now it was hilarious as members of the
media pretending like Ilhan Omar had
never done any of this stuff saying oh
look at pens getting on getting all
partisan about this um on the Foreign
Affairs Committee is an open anti-semite
she's a Democrat the Democrats decided
to cover for her
it wasn't like pence who made this
partisan it wasn't Bibi Netanyahu made
this partisan it was Democrats who made
this partisan now I do have to give
props today to Stinney Hoyer the house
Mynor of the House Majority Whip he came
out and essentially by name blasted
Ilhan Omar this takes some spine spine
that Nancy Pelosi doesn't have here was
Stinney Hoyer doing the right thing and
coming after al hahn omar sadly he
should have done this when it was up for
debate in the house he didn't then but
at least he's doing it now better late
than never accuses american supporters
of dual loyalty I say accuse me so let's
have debates on policy instead of
impugning the loyalty of Israel's
supporters that is why I opposed those
who pushed for boycotts divestment and
sanctions against Israel by the way
there are 62 freshmen Democrats you hear
me
62 not three good for him I mean that's
him calling out Ilhan Omar he's the
House Majority Leader sorry not the
weapon yeah that was a far cry from
Nancy Pelosi who speaking at AIPAC said
generally she's against anti-semitism no
specific words with regards to Ilhan
Omar because again she is a coward sandy
Hoyer apparently is not her tower does
however rules the day in the Democratic
Party the for house came together
condemn the anti-semitic myth of dual
loyalty and all form is bigotry with a
resolution that quote rejects the
perpetuation of anti-semitic stereotypes
in the United States and around the
world including the pernicious myth of
dual loyalty and foreign allegiance
especially in the context of support for
the United States Israel alliance to
have any of the guts to actually come
out against Ilhan Omar in any of this
and that would be a very good time it
turns out to be an Israel supporter
considering the Hamas is randomly firing
rocket
into the middle of civilian centers in
Israel in Hamas is an evil disgusting
vicious terrorist group that is
interested in wiping every Jew out of
the Middle East if not all across the
face of the world and the Democrats
couldn't contend Mel hen Omar they could
not do it that is not the foot by the
way and Bibi Netanyahu spoke at AIPAC as
well and he went after Ilhan Omar
directly here's what he had to say from
this Benjamin it's not about the
Benjamins the reason the people of
America is not because they want our
money it's because they share our values
they just don't get it it's because
America and Israel share a love of
freedom and democracy and of course
that's true
Ilhan omar promptly tweeted back in its
new yahoo well you're under indictment
for corruption so obviously it is about
the Benjamins that the words of a woman
who's truly contrite about her
anti-semitism again it wasn't the right
that made israel a partisan issue was
the democrats who decided to break with
israel at least Stinney Hoyer and some
democrats are now saying the right
things even if they're too cowardly to
do so in public when it actually counts
okay time for some things i like and
then we'll do some things that I hate so
things that I like today there is a new
movie that is out video-on-demand
that is actually it's a good movie it's
a really good movie the the it's called
dragged across a concrete the guy who
directed it I'm trying to remember his
name I believe it's Saleh and he has
made some really kind of weird and
interesting movies s Craig's Allah he
made bone tomahawk which is a weird and
interesting movie this this movie is
essentially about two cops who are
booted from the forest they are
suspended from the police force for not
really racism a kind of excessive force
and they are called racist in the
process even though they were not being
racist at the time and then they decide
that they are going to rob a criminal
they're going to rob a criminal to make
monies that they can support themselves
the movie has been characterized as
reactionary it probably is in the same
vein as Deathwish it's worth watching it
doesn't move very fast but it is it is
very powerful it's good it's good stuff
there's a reason I'm sitting behind this
desk running things
you're out there with a partner this 20
years younger than you
Anthony's got a mouth with his own
engine but he's solid not thinking about
the kind of future I can offer my
girlfriend Pop's is a yesterday who
ain't worth words when heavens and
praise be they your absence was a weight
upon us Thank You mr. Edmonton
I don't like doing things with so many
question marks everywhere okay so the
movie is extraordinarily brutal but it's
got a couple of it's got a couple of
notes that are super conservative that
are pretty astonishing so go check it
out dragged across concrete it's
available on Amazon Prime video
on-demand it's really good Mel Gibson is
terrific in it it really is I mean it's
a part that fits invincible none is very
good in it as well so go check out
dragged across concrete well worth the
watch okay other things that I like
today so this is just hilarious quote a
major Greenland glacier that was one of
the fastest shrinking ice and snow
masses on earth is growing again a new
NASA study finds this according to NBC
News the Jacob Swan glacier around 2012
was retreating about 1.8 miles and
thinning nearly 130 feet annually but it
started growing again at about the same
rate in the past two years according to
a study in Monday's Nature Geoscience
study authors and outside scientists
think this is temporary that was kind of
a surprise we kind of got used to a
runaway system said geological survey of
Denmark and Greenland ice and climate
scientists at Jason box the good news is
it's a reminder that it's not
necessarily going that fast but it is
going so they keep suggesting that it is
continuing to go but they were surprised
by all of this listen maybe in the long
term their estimates continue to be
correct but it is weird how climate
scientists keep getting surprised by the
data every so often now I'm not saying
this is somebody who denies the climate
changes taking place I've said many
times before that the IPCC estimates
when it comes to climate change I'm fine
with accepting those I don't have a
general problem with all of that however
when you're computer modeling is wrong
so often you might need to think about
your predictive capacity because the
IPCC report does have a range of
possibilities that it offers and the
IPCC report has consistently
overestimated the amount of global
warming they thought was going to take
place particularly at the upper end of
that estimate okay time for a couple of
things that I hate
so in the aftermath of proving that
President Trump was a Russian tool now
the New York Times is an to proving that
God doesn't exist that's exciting they
have an opinion piece by a philosophy
professor named Peter Atherton he is a
professor of philosophy at San Diego
State University so his credentials are
well in line he has a piece today called
a god problem perfect all-knowing
all-powerful the idea of the deity most
Westerners accept is actually not
coherent and then it proceeds to lay out
in about 850 words a sophomoric argument
that ignores no probably 3,000 years of
Western philosophy it has a professor of
philosophy and he doesn't know the most
basic to mystic arguments about the
existence of God or maimana daeun
arguments about the existence of God in
other words he's a dilettante when it
comes to religious philosophy which is
true for a lot of people who think that
they know what they're writing about
when it comes to religious philosophy
for those of us who spend a lot of our
time studying religious philosophy just
as religious human beings his complaints
are nothing new it's funny when you hear
people who have spent no time examining
religious philosophy go well you know if
God knows everything that's gonna happen
then how do you have free will and say
god you're right you've you've thought
you've hit upon it no one in the history
of philosophy has thought of these
questions not going back to Augustine
not moving forward through Maimonides
nobody's ever thought about these
problems you yourself have hit upon it
now now you're right if we just thought
about these questions when they say how
couldn't all good God allow bad things
to happen you're right it's the first
time anyone's ever asked this question
kudos to you it's so lazy in my book the
right side of history I do discuss these
questions and I give some very basic
answers that virtually all Western
philosophers particularly in the
judeo-christian tradition agree upon but
this this this is basically he
legitimately raises the question I'm not
kidding you he legitimately raises the
can God make a rock so large that he
can't pick it up question which is
introduced in theology classes in like
sophomore year of high school for the
record there are two particular
perspectives on this prospective number
one is God can do anything so he can
even violate the laws of logic and then
there's the general judeo-christian view
the two mystic view and the my manatee
and view which is that god cannot
violate the rules of logic because he
created the rules of logic so God cannot
be both something and not something God
not be both a square and a circle which
is one of the reasons why Maimonides is
constantly suggesting that you can't
affirmative ly describe God you can only
describe God in terms of what he can't
be and so God does not take physical
form according to Maimonides because
that would actually contradict the rules
of his existence in any case this
article is just more proof that the New
York Times for for them this constitutes
deep philosophy it's so dumb I mean this
article is really silly so he talks
about he talks about the question of
evil he says if God is morally perfect
it is difficult to see why he wouldn't
have created a morally perfect world so
why didn't he
he says the standard defense is that
evil is necessary for a free will
however this does not explain so-called
physical evil like suffering caused by
non human causes like famines
earthquakes etc well yeah actually it
does because if it turned out that the
universe actually just reacted in
positive ways to you doing good things
that wouldn't be freewill in other words
there has to be the patina of chaos in
order for you to make freely will
decisions again very very basic stuff
very basic stuff in judeo-christian
philosophy they say what about
omniscience philosophically this
presents us with no less of a conundrum
leaving aside the highly implausible
idea that God knows all the facts in the
universe they just say that it's
implausible why is it implausible
because this philosopher says so if God
knows all there is to know then he knows
at least as much as we know but if he
knows what we know then this would
appear to detract from his perfection
now why would that why would perfect
knowledge to track from his perfection
because if they were known to God that
would make him a sinner
he says if God knows all that is
knowable God must know things that we do
like lust and envy but one cannot know
Westin envy unless one has experienced
them well no that's that's idiotic
you can know what lust and envy are
without quote-unquote experiencing them
and the experience or lust of envy does
not necessarily connote evil if you
created the experiences themselves then
why examine this what that doesn't even
that doesn't even match up also there's
the notion that virtue and again this is
too mystic notion that God created
everything with an innate level of
perfection and then human beings with
free will have detracted from that so
for example lust started off as helpful
sexual desire for members of the
opposite sex and when we and when we
are not perfect when we exercise our
will in bad ways our desires in bad ways
and that turns into lust I said what
about malice could God no analysis like
and still retain his divine goodness
that all of this is so Southam auric but
unfortunately sophomoric religious
philosophy is stock-in-trade for for the
New York Times hey speaking of
sophomoric San Antonio has now barred
chick-fil-a from their Airport because
chick-fil-a is owned by people who are
pro traditional marriage and that's very
bad chick-fil-a sells chicken sandwiches
if you didn't know that's what they do I
wasn't aware that the chickens were gay
or straight I wasn't aware that they
barred gay people from buying their
chicken sandwiches in fact I didn't do
any of that stuff you'll recall that
chick-fil-a opened on a Sunday which
they don't normally do in the middle of
the Orlando pulse shooting to help take
care of people who are doing rescue and
cleanup and protesting and all of that
sort of stuff but chick-fil-a very very
bad and so they must be shut down people
who don't know basic religious
philosophy make assumptions about
religious people that are simply false
that religious people are malicious that
religious people think that if you sin
then this makes you an inherently bad
human being in a way different from
people who are religious that religious
people believe that only religious
people can be good which is obviously
false it's so funny my new book the
right side of history I've been asked
about it a few times on left-wing
podcast there's one from The Economist
the other day where they asked me this
and the first question people always ask
is so what you're saying is that
religious people are the only good
people say no I'm not saying that read
the book of course I'm not saying that
there are lots of great atheists and
there are lots of bad religious people
what I'm saying is you can't build a
civilized foundation on the basis of
pure scientific materialism that's the
case that I'm making in any case
silliness about religion is undergirding
part of the attack on the West and
that's a problem all right well we will
be back here for two more hours later
today we'll have updates we have a great
guest today like I'm very excited about
our guest today showing up a little bit
later today Thomas solo will be stopping
by to discuss his book disparities and
discrimination I will talk about racism
and disparities and in various areas of
American life we'll also be talking with
Maajid Nawaz who's a philosopher and a
reform at Muslim he will be stopping by
to talk about the problem of radical
Islam among other issues also we should
be having on Rafer Weigel from Chicago
from ABC 7 in Chicago to talk about the
the justice Milan case a lots of good
stuff happening this afternoon
please go and and make sure that you you
subscribe ninety-nine bucks a year got
to a subscription and we'll see a little
bit later today or we'll see you here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam Tsai
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
I'm Michael novel's host of the Michael
Noel's show Democrats already in the
throes of their worst week since 1865
now suffer a further indignity a federal
court has invalidated Obamacare in its
entirety the DOJ agrees it just keeps
getting better and better go to daily
wire comm to check it out